à quel moment doit-on peut-on être
munichois est ce que vous avez trouvé
une ligne quelque chose d'un faillible
qui nous permette de décider sans avoir
peur du regard de l'histoire
j'ai pas trouvé le remède infaillible ce
que je peux dire c'est qu'en
reconsidérant le phénomène de munich
c'est à dire de la capitulation devant
des religions ce allemande pour la
tchécoslovaquie illusions et était de ne
pas voir que cette cette montée cette
volonté hégémonique de l'allemagne
hitlérienne avec son idée d'une race
supérieure qui a été fait pour coloniser
notamment les peuples slaves en europe
on n'avait pas vu que c'était que
c'était ça alex ancien l' on a cru que
en faisant une concession elle même de
doses basée sur le droit des peuples à
disposer puisque il y avait une minorité
allemande en tchécoslovaquie
on allait pouvoir calmer la bête donc si
vous voulez dans chaque cas il peut voir
un peu la situation et laroque non
aujourd'hui pour l'europe
si on pense à la russie ce n'est pas une
puissance y est animé par une volonté
aujourd'hui hégémonique de dominer le
monde c'est une puissance qui essayent
de repas de rassembler des morceaux à
l'ancien empire des jeux dont d'horrible
et il faut voir au cas par cas moi je
pose la question de la d expédition
américaine en irak
bien sûr réseau détruit un dictateur
mais ils sont produits des mots
innombrables et je ne suis pas là pour
comptabiliser si les maux provoqués par
cette intervention sont plus grands que
s'il dictateur qui était mortel avait
continué mais je pense que les
interventions américaines au
moyen-orient où était catastrophique et
on veut graver le court catastrophique
des choses je pense que chaque situation
méric une examen une contextualisations
historique et géographique
et qu'on ne peut pas avoir un principe
général aujourd'hui de pacifisme ou au
contraire ce acceptait la guerre
[Musique]